well landlords of a problem apartment
complex given another chance the 8 news
now i-team has been reporting on the
apex apartments there at twain and
cambridge since last august and our
i-team's vanessa murphy was in court
this morning as there were some
fireworks between a judge clark county
and lawyers for the landlords
a judge is giving the apex apartments
another extension to fix issues at the
property one priority she says air
conditioning as we're in the 100 plus
degree heat she says that's part of
making sure the place is sufficient to
live in but that's just one of the many
issues identified in court here for me
this is an emotional issue and it has to
do with these people's livelihoods and
them being mistreated by a landlord
who's trying to save as much money as
possible attorney timothy allen is
representing clark county which is suing
the owners of the apex apartments
california-based pro residential bought
the property in january of 2021 and has
been operating without a license still
collecting rent money and covet 19 rent
relief money the county points to
dangerous living conditions and a major
spike in crime including four murders
today as a direct result of apex's
conduct four people have died jason
hicks represents the apex apartments who
are they you have no evidence you don't
even know the names of these people i
don't know their names i don't know
their circumstances hicks says the
landlords want to shut the apartment
complex down to make repairs the county
pointing to the affordable housing
crisis and not being able to find new
homes for tenants judge jessica peterson
expressing frustration would you like to
return all of that rental money to the
tenants well they've got a service for
that they lived there they had a roof
over their head
you don't get to have your cake and then
your two council i'm not asking for it
yeah you are she's giving the landlords
about a month to make a list of repairs
and the cost of the repairs along with a
list of tenants and she's giving them
permission to evict tenants who refused
to pay rent before her order in may
resident travis smith says he hopes the
place improves i don't want the apex to
shut down
you know i want
i just want the community we have before
they took it over the next court date is
set for july 12th reporting in downtown
las vegas vanessa murphy live local now